welcome to the third season of the
official community guide video series
for ARMA 3 my name is lexi and in
cooperation with Bohemia Interactive I'm
creating a series of videos to explain
some of the basics of ARMA 3 if you're
new to the community guides be sure to
also check out the previous episodes
which focus on topics like infantry
combat multiplayer teamwork and
helicopters as with ARMA 3 in general
helicopter usage is a deep topic with
many facets to it today we'll be
expanding on how to use them in combat
more specifically let's look at how to
execute a basic helicopter born air
assault we'll go over this from start to
finish from the initial pickup to the
extraction phase after the missions been
completed the benefits of air assaults
lie on the mobility and flexibility that
they offer helicopters fly fast low and
you can land pretty much anywhere that
you can fit the rotors into with
sufficient helicopters or multiple
flights you can transport a large number
of infantry practically anywhere you
need to in a short period of time as
well as pick them up and reposition them
for new objectives with relative ease
it's a welcomed option considering the
massive terrain sizes of the Altis and
Stratis islands
to start out the person in command of
the mission will be choosing the landing
zones for his elements and breathe them
to the pilots the pilots in turn will
assess these landing zones and adjust
them as necessary based on their own
personal experiences when choosing a
landing zone consider what threats you
are likely to be facing your mission
briefing whether it's a single-player or
multiplayer scenario should give you an
idea of this but remember that it could
be misleading generally speaking you
want to play it safe it's better to walk
a bit further after landing than to
never land at all look for L Z's that
are in positions that mask them from the
most likely directions of enemy fire or
observation when your pilot's are
capable try to pick landing zones close
to cover and concealment such that the
dismounting infantry can immediately
take up protected positions to fight
from once the main landing zone or zones
have been chosen pick at least one
alternate LZ this is done so that in the
event that the primary LZ is unsuitable
for whatever reason
pilots can quickly move to land in an
alternate that's been chosen carefully
in advance instead of as a
spur-of-the-moment decision when flying
large elements such as platoons into an
area picking several different al Z's
and sending different helicopters to
each will help to spread the unit out
and give it more tactical flexibility of
on landing the vast and varied terrain
of Altis and Stratis will make this a
constant topic for evaluation not every
location will have obvious landing zones
and you may have to be rather creative
when the terrain seems stacked against
you there are a few additional
considerations to help ensure a safe
landing the most obvious is having a
gunship escort and prep the LZ in
advance of the transports arriving this
isn't always possible due to mission
design but when available it's a great
way to provide security to the landings
the next best thing is to have a scout
aircraft one which can fly in the LZ and
take a look around shortly before the
transports arrive some transport
aircraft like the Hellcat of powerful
cameras it can observe an area from a
safe distance if you have this sort of
capability use it when these aren't
available a decision must be made about
how to approach the LZ either by flying
directly into it or spending a bit of
time orbiting it to scout it out before
landing choosing the land multiple
aircraft at the same time can result in
unexpected enemy fire dispersing amongst
many targets as well as having many
weapons to turn that fire
whereas flying in single aircraft one at
a time can allow the other aircraft
option
used to wait law firm ha tells these or
provide aerial gunnery support during
the landings once all squads and pilots
have been briefed on their landing zones
and objectives it's time to load up a
troop load in a helicopter is known as a
chalk due to cargo limitations an
element such as a squad may not all fit
into one helo it's important to make
sure that each chalk has a leader in it
such as a squad or a fireteam leader
these leaders are extremely important
they ensure that their chalks loading
the correct helo they notify the pilot
when the chocks loaded and they provide
leadership at the landing zone until
such time as they can merge back into
their parent unit the flight from the
pickup zone to the landing zone must be
carefully planned for avoiding any known
enemy locations is of course a key
element and the altitude and path chosen
will be based unknown as well as
suspected enemy threats flying high
works well in environments where the
threat is primarily based on machine
guns and other such weapons with limited
range and targeting capabilities but it
doesn't work so well when missile
systems are present on the other hand
flying low makes one vulnerable to
machine guns and similar threats but
generally makes it hard for them or
missile systems to engage the aircraft
due to low exposure times and masking
terrain trees and similar of course if
you flying low it's essential to have
good pilots who know their own
capabilities and are able to avoid any
obstacles such as power lines that might
present themselves during low-level
flight
the final approach to the landing zone
requires the utmost and concentration
from the pilots as well as door Gunners
a good LZ approach is done in a smooth
controlled fashion being able to
promptly land without floundering around
is necessary to give any enemies as
little time as possible to react to the
presence of the helicopters note that
pilots have the final say here it can
call for a wave off or alternate LZ if
they deem it necessary the pilots are
the ones who know their capabilities and
can make judgment calls about any
threats or obstacles in the LZ s if they
say they can't make it and they need to
wave off or convert that's how it's
going to be once an aircraft touches
down the pilots the one who calls for
dismount typically by saying go go go
this is due to the fact that only the
pilot truly knows when he's fully landed
if embark troops try to dismount on
their own discretion they may find that
the first step out the door is
unpleasantly long when the troops have
fully dismounted the chaulk leader tells
the pilot he's clear to depart the helos
crew chief will also observe the
interior the aircraft and if he sees
that all the troops depart he tells the
pilot as well
the pilot leaves when either the chaulk
leader or the crew chief tells me is
empty
if the LZ is hot which is to say that
enemy fire is being received during the
landing the crew chief and door gunner
will suppress known or suspected enemy
locations upon landing the whole fire to
avoid hitting the dismounting troops
after they take off they can resume
their fire when taking off pilots
communicate their takeoff directions to
each other in order to avoid mid-air
collisions while this direction should
have been planned for in advance and
briefed accordingly unexpected contact
of the LZ can cause an alternate route
to be decided on the spot once all
troops have been dropped off helos can
either return to base and anticipation
of fairing and reinforcements to
resupply or they can stay in the areas
reconnaissance or light air support this
is based on the nature the threats in
the area of operations so don't expect
the aircraft to stick around with heavy
machine guns vehicles or anti-air
missiles likely to show up in the fight
at some point an extraction will be
required as with the initial landing
this too requires careful execution to
pull off safely when preparing for an
extraction ground forces attempt to move
away from known or suspected them any
threats
searching for a pickup zone that fulfils
the same criteria as the original
landing zone once identified ground
forces move to the pickup zone and
establish security around it ground
leaders establish what order they'll
extract in where the first elements be
picked up staying closest to the pickup
site while the other ones provide
security the pickup zone location is
communicated to the aircraft and if
necessary the ground commander deploys
smoke once the lead aircraft is thirty
seconds out when operating nighttime
conditions infrared strobes lasers and
such can be used to covertly mark
landing zone while chemical lights and
smoke grenades can be combined to give a
very visible landing zone marker when
light discipline is not a concern once
the aircraft's on the deck remember that
for any given chalk the leader will load
in the aircraft last he may have another
person providing security close to the
landed helo while the others load up but
once he knows his chalk is loaded he
communicates this to the pilot so the
speedy liftoff can occur this process is
repeated squad by squad and the aircraft
by aircraft until the pickup zone has
been completely evacuated now when all
said and done you return back to base
after successful mission congratulations
are in order what you've conducted her
participated in wasn't a stage cinematic
event it was a living breathing dynamic
experience it took skill knowledge and
coordination to pull off successfully
this sort of depth is a hallmark of the
ARMA series if you're anything like me
so it keeps you coming back again and
again
[Music]
now if you'd like to know more about
helicopter tactics I'd recommend
checking out my ARMA 3 tackle guide
which you can find on the Bohemia
Interactive store for more community
guide videos be sure to subscribe to the
official ARMA 3 YouTube channel for
other ARMA 3 updates keep track of the
official website Facebook and Twitter
pages if you'd like more in-depth
tutorial and multiplayer gameplay of
ARMA 3 and the previous ARMA titles I'd
recommend you check out my channel here
this is dyslexia major LZs always be
interesting